the King of Fighters 14 is yet another
satisfying entry in the long-running KOF
series the latest installment ditches
the intricate sprites found in previous
games in favor of 3d characters and
backgrounds though battles still take
place on a 2d plane this change is bound
to turn off those you might favor the
older visual style however ko f-14s core
fighting mechanics live up to the
series's legacy offering a new system
that expands upon those from its
predecessor while sticking close to its
three-on-three format ko f-14 is an
engrossing fighter that exceeds the
initial impressions of it's bland
presentation offering an experience well
worth your time whether you're a
hardcore fan of the series or not
Rocky
KOF 14 pits you against teams of three
fighters in a series of one-on-one
battles when one character is defeated
the match resets as the next character
in line is brought in to continue the
fight returning players will notice the
difference in movement speed from past
games right away the game seemingly
slows down the energetic action of KOF
13 but this doesn't diminish the
exciting nature of fights battles remain
tense and exhilarating especially once
you get a feel for the pace of combat
and combo timing with the cast of 50
characters the game offers plenty of
different play styles that are each
distinct from another and they're
movesets while it's uplifting to see
such a large cast composed of both
favorites and newcomers it's unfortunate
that the new 3d character models while
serviceable do little to bring their
personalities to life they're far cry
from the dynamic 2d sprites from the
series is past showcasing only a faint
glimmer what made seeing these
characters so memorable and endearing
despite the less than stellar visuals
KOF 4 teams new fighting system is its
most striking quality its streamlines
mechanics we've seen in the past while
introducing expansive techniques and
options for combos the result is a
fighting system that's easier to
understand and more fulfilling to engage
with there are three major mechanics to
manage max mode super advanced climax
cancels and rush max mode is a state you
trigger that grants you the ability to
perform more powerful versions of your
characters special moves these proved
useful in turning the tide of battle
since these beefed up moves can be
linked with other moves to create even
more powerful combos then there's a
multiple ways of cancelling moves into
supers which are essential for executing
destructive combos when done properly
cancelling can be an effective means of
beating opponents during a tough squeeze
canceling out one attack and beginning
another more powerful one allows you to
turn a single move into a custom combo
and with three ways to cancel moves in
Kol 14 this opens up a wealth of
opportunities for players of all skill
levels to deliver a series of
devastating attacks
lastly rush is a unique combo that you
can perform a repeatedly pressing light
punch the attack is suited for beginners
looking for a way to strike back at
their opponent this may raise red flags
for advanced players however this weakly
powered attack is balanced accordingly
requiring you to be right next to an
opponent to before
these new mechanics help make ko f-14s
combo focus fighting system more
straightforward and as a result it's the
most inviting entry in the series thus
far though that doesn't necessarily
downplay the finesse in strategic
planning during a fight you're still
required to understand the fundamentals
of execution and positioning if you hope
to succeed thankfully the path to
understanding the intricacies of KO f-14
is a welcoming one as there's a bunch of
in-game tutorials available to get you
up to speed on the series as established
mechanics there's also a trial mode that
educates you on combos you can perform
with each character providing you with a
general idea of what attacks and special
moves each character can link together
once you've outfitted yourself with the
basic knowledge to fight there are
plenty of modes to test your skills in
like past games there's a story mode
that allows you to fight against ten
stages worth of CPU opponents but if
you're expecting anything similar to the
recent story modes from other fighters
you're going to be disappointed the
narrative is vague and nearly
non-existent if you're looking to
compete against other players online the
good news is that servers are smooth and
stable thus far lagging only when facing
a player with a poor connection and high
ping with plenty of opportunities
available online or off ko f-14s a well
executed addition to the revered series
if you remain steadfast and parsing
through the multiple layers of its
mechanics you'll be rewarded with one of
the most accessible and satisfying
entries in the series to date